this morning in our eye on earth series
we explore how climate change threatens
Penguins in a place few people have
visited a new US government report found
the last decade was the hottest ever
recorded on earth and 2019 was the
second hottest year ever measured
raising new concerns about climate
change one of the places seriously
affected Antarctica Roxana Saberi went
there to understand how penguins are
being impacted by the warming
temperatures good morning Antarctica is
one of the most remote places on the
planet but climate change is hitting it
hard we're here with a group of
scientists who want to know how the
warming weather is affecting this
particular species of penguin the
chinstrap elephant island is so
far-flung few people have set foot on
these rocky shores it took us three days
of sailing with environmental activists
from Greenpeace crashing through waves
and climbing across rubber rafts to join
scientists counting penguins why count
penguins they come back to the same
place to nest every year which means we
can really keep tabs on their
populations by observing penguins we can
get an idea of the health of this this
whole area Alex Borowitz observes
nesting areas like this where one parent
babysits
while another travels down at penguin
highway to fish for krill then hikes
back up to feed its chick the shrimp
like food the scientists from Stony
Brook and northeastern University's
count each chaotic colony on foot with
mechanical clickers and scan them from
above with high-tech drones all tecee of
this population of chinstrap penguins is
dwindling like elsewhere in the region
the researchers are traveling on
Greenpeace ships from island to island
across the Antarctic Peninsula they're
comparing different penguin populations
to see how they're adapting to climate
change here it may not look like it but
this is one of the fastest warming areas
on earth one nearby island is actually
called penguin island over the past four
decades its chinstrap population has
plunged by 75% the numbers have dropped
across the region as temperatures have
soared by more than five degrees over 50
years that's about five times the global
average so when we see climate change
impacting things down here glacial melt
warming oceans more acidic oceans
penguins do really interact with with
all of those things so do krill
chinstraps favorite food
they depend on sea ice to survive sea
ice is really what brings all of the
ocean so with less sea ice there's less
krill so less food for the chinstrap
penguins that's the idea after days of
counting chinstraps on elephant island
21 22 22 the scientists invited us onto
their ship 30 to watch them crunch
numbers from one nesting site okay so
they've lost already 50% since there
well that's amazing that fits the
pattern they're seeing on the island so
far the decline of around 150,000
chinstraps and since the last major
survey fifty years ago another sign the
researchers say this penguin population
is collapsing across the region it's
very dramatic to have a wildlife
population declined by 50% and
unexploited wildlife populace they're
not haunted
and you think climate change is the main
reason behind i think climate change is
driving almost all of the processes down
here now in a way that they've never
experienced before
penguins are a lot like people they need
food in a good environment to thrive
these researchers say if the world
continues to warm these birds can show
us how other species even human beings
will be affected by climate change for
CBS this morning Roxana Saberi Elephant
Island Antarctica wow that's a big drop
and I tell you what they depend on
what's in the ocean you don't know who
else eats a lot of things from the ocean
yeah we do but I keep hearing Morgan
Freeman's voice from the mic I know it
looked exactly like that yeah and
they're so cute I really want them to
thrive yeah population cut in half very
very scary worried
you